[Musique]
dans cette nouvelle émission des
municipales la dernière avant l'été deux
invités en plateau pour m'accompagner
aujourd'hui alain georges bonjour vous
êtes maire communiste de la verrière et
pire le guérinel bonjour quand j'étais
vice président de l'udps et
départementales lui dei qui a tenu le
vendredi 12 juillet une conférence de
presse autour de son nouveau président
alain richard pour leur nom arnaud
richard pardon pour parler des
orientations que souhaite prendre le
parti de jean-louis borloo on en croit
dans quelques instants alain jaj tout
d'abord est ce que vous serez candidat
en mars 2014 à la verrière oui gros
suspense non non il n'y a pas de
suspense je suis élu depuis deux ans
donc évidemment je serai candidat alors
en plus avec un certain avantage même
par certains avantages puisque les les
deux sections bernoise du parti
communiste et du parti socialiste se
sont associés à votre candidature c'est
une bonne nouvelle oui c'est vrai que
c'est même la première fois depuis
longtemps tout cas que deux formations
politiques déclare aussitôt leur
intention de partir ensemble à deux
municipales et aussi vite et aussi vite
dans les bonnes conditions dans les
bonnes conditions c'est à dire que là
des conditions de confiance puisque nous
nous avons déclaré que nous souhaitions
travailler avec les verriers roi sur un
programme une liste de manière ouverte
ensemble et donc en confiance c'est la
confiance en moi oui parce que vous le
disiez effectivement c'est pas fréquent
en mars 2008 votre prédécesseur pierre
sennes un cours l'ancien maire qui se
rappelle à quitter la mairie un peu plus
d'un an avait dû faire face à deux
listes de gauche celle menée par fou si
moussa et puis de l'iss par nos pigistes
aussi mené par pascal gervans alors ils
l'avaient emporté lui au premier tour
pierre c'est l'impôt il avait quand même
trois listes phase aller avec 50 points
75 % des voix il dans quel état d'esprit
vous partez au bompard
comme dans toute élection vous savez il
faut d'abord la gagne et donc il faut
s'y préparer il est encore tôt on n'aime
pas encore en campagne il ya le temps
encore gérer les affaires communales
mais on part confiant d'un bilan
que les verrières roy ont l'air de juger
bon et puis des projets des perspectives
sur lesquelles les verriers roy semble
en accord donc c'est des bonnes
conditions je reviens sur cet accord pc
ps s'est déroulée comment les
négociations comment ça se passe dans
ces cas-là on sait de section se
retrouve à une qui appelle l'autre en
dix ans j'aimerais bien te rencontrer
pour qu'on parle des municipales ont en
réalité c'est beaucoup plus simple que
ça on se parle régulièrement
heureusement d'ailleurs on se parle
régulièrement et puis un moment donné on
se dit les temps de se dire les choses
c'est à dire de de marquer une volonté
un accord est donc on s'est retrouvés ya
pas très longtemps pour se dire le
moment est venu avant l'été j'avoue
aussi qu'ils avaient la volonté
d'afficher une volonté de rassemblement
de regroupement et peut-être d'exemple à
l'échelle de l'agglomération alors
exemple alicia la vénération vous pensez
à magny les hameaux peut-être quand
je pense que c'est bien que je vois pas
se poser à guyancourt
du 3 au 6 août et moi je pense que les
formations de gauche
parti socialiste parti communiste
écologiste parti de gauche ont intérêt à
se rejoindre se regrouper et à prendre
le temps surtout de travailler sur des
éléments de programme je crois que ce
qu'attendent les habitants c'est pas
tant la petite salade interne pour
savoir comment vont être composer les
listes et les responsabilités ils ont
envie de savoir comment les projets vont
s'élaborer et savoir s'ils vont pouvoir
participer à cela et donc pour partir un
petit peu tôt pour se mettre en
condition de travailler ensemble en moi
je m'intéresse quand même un peu à la
salle interne sur la question quand on
est un accord comme ça entre pc ps on se
doute que est ce que les places sont
déjà définis sur les listes c'est à dire
vous vous êtes pc donc vous serez tête
de liste le numéro 2 sera plutôt ps est
ce qu'il ya un échange comme ça
paritaire entre les deux parties j'ai
parlé de confiance tout à l'heure et
justement nous n'avons pas fait cela
nous avons dit ces questions là elles
viendront le moment les répartitions
bien sûr on s'est mis d'accord sur le
renouvellement du maire donc le maire
soit tête de liste va de soi comme
préalable d'un accord ensuite pour le
reste non nous avons dit notre accord
une porte sur de notre volonté de
travailler ensemble au projet et à la
constitution de la liste sachant vous
savez très bien que dans les petites
villes mais dans les grandes également
aujourd'hui ce ne sont pas que des
militants des partis qui forment les
listes aujourd'hui il y a des gens qui
ont envie de se retrouver sur un projet
qui ne sont pas des rangs d'une
formation politique qui ont envie de
participer à la démarche d'action
municipale donc voilà il tôt on fait
dans l'ordre d'abord le projet et puis
ensuite la liste on va parler aussi un
peu d enjeu de campagne entre ce qui se
dessine et roxon on les devine avec tous
les changements que la ville connaît
depuis quand même quelques mois mais si
on veut concurrent les listes
concurrentes parce que vous êtes des
échos parce que l'ump par exemple vous
n'êtes pas représentons car les carnets
de riz np vous êtes en sommes voilà de
l'idée mais malgré tout sur la droite
l'ump n'a pas encore désigné de deux
têtes de liste sur sur la verrière on
évoque nicolas dainville qui a été qui
s'est fait connaître sur la commune
ensembles collectifs la verrière pour la
famille il fait aussi partie d'ensemble
pour la verrière et s'intéresse beaucoup
aux notions d' emploi de cadre de vie de
famille etc est ce que c'est une
candidature qui n'est pas encore
annoncée l'intéressé dit réfléchir à
cette possibilité mais est ce que c'est
une histoire qui vous fait peur écoutez
quand un inconnu commencent à
s'intéresser à la verrière et aux
verriers roi et et arrive
et arrive avec effectivement cette
démarche
de contacts et autres sur des thèmes
divers mais on regarde on voit bien que
en tout cas j'ai l'impression du côté
des locaux on regarde attentivement j'ai
l'impression qu'on y prend une place
assez active sa passion est liée à il
est lié à jean michel faure 600 cédant
renoncer parce qu'il n'a distance
parlement bien sûr c'est pas ce qu'il
dit il se présente évidemment pas comme
ça enfin c'est pas très compliqué de
voir à peu près d'où il vient et on sent
qu effectivement elancourt s'intéresse
beaucoup à la verrière très bien moi je
dis et les candidats et qui est une
liste ump me paraît tout à fait normal
en démocratie par contre faut dire faut
dire qui on est ce qu'on est quelles
sont ses impressions son programme avec
la manifestation la manif pour tous il a
quand même un fichier certains de ses
valeurs au cola lui l'affiché des
valeurs mais vous savez on est sur une
élection municipale et les verrières roi
ils vont être attentif à avoir
effectivement des candidats et une tête
de liste qui connaissent la ville qui
connaissent les dossiers qui connaît ses
sujets et qui soit force de proposition
et pas simplement dans une démarche
politicienne
comment vous regardez la verrière
en voisin
de staël ou une réponse
non réellement voisin parce que quel que
soit les élus des deux villes ils ont
nécessairement à travailler ensemble
alors voyez c'est pas parce que
hallinger front de gauche et moi pas que
c'est interdit les choses les
circonstances ont fait qu'il y ait un
dossier commun qui est l'accès à la gare
de la verrière bien les circonstances
ont fait que les élus sont retrouvés
c'est toute la différence entre ce que
disait elle à il ya quelques instants
entre des élections municipales qui ont
des enjeux très particulier de vie
courante et puis d'autres niveaux
pendant lesquelles on peut effectivement
afficher des valeurs plus précisément ou
d'une autre façon parce que à ce moment
là les enjeux l'autoriser ou le rendre
presque obligatoire
préciser parce que oui les gens qui ne
savent pas vous êtes 10 présent du des
plateaux mais vous êtes aussi mais je
suis maire par intérim c'est pas trés le
premier adjoint
pendant l'absence de georges mougeot
comme il est de règle il faut un
remplaçant en attendant le retour du
maire donc oui j'essaie de le rendre
vous avez terminé en plus à travailler
sur
ce cas que ce sont les circonstances de
fait et de temps mais donc ça prouve que
les élus municipaux mais d'ailleurs on
le sait tous à quel que soit leur
appartenance politique il y à un moment
où il faut se mettre autour de la même
table parce que les enjeux sont les
mêmes alors du coup est-ce que vous avez
des infos à donner à linge sur une
éventuelle candidature à
la vie j'ai noté beaucoup d'intérêt
le très grand intérêt que prend la ville
d'elancourt à tout le périmètre
géographique qui l'entourent parce que
manifestement ça ne touche pas que la
verrière
ça touche aussi malsain puis d'autres
communes
voilà
on n'est pas là pour parler
c'est pas lui je pensais
je reviens sur les enjeux de campagne
sur la verrière on se doute que c'est
effectivement la guerre on a parlé des
abords de la gare et les bécanes ce sera
vraiment le vôtre avis des thèmes
centraux de cette campagne même si vous
me dites elle est là des campagnes pas
encore débuté elle a débuté en septembre
mais vous ce sera des axes forts j'ai
depuis mon élection il choisit trois
axes importants et donc je pense que
c'est là dessus que la campagne se fera
probablement le premier c'est quand même
tout ce que représentent les services
publics et les services au public ou les
services semi-public d'ailleurs pour la
population aujourd'hui ceux-ci sont
souvent
attaqués par l'austérité et donc les
diminutions de moyens donc on avait des
risques forts donc on est sur tous ces
sujets plutôt à la confortation et à
l'accompagnement surtout en période de
crise
j'ai pensé évidemment à la fermeture de
la paix mis par exemple qui était en
cause la diminution des des effectifs
l'année dernière sur le collège
d'enseignants etc donc tout ça c'est un
travail que nous faisons mais nous
essayons plutôt de conforter le service
public parce qu'aujourd'hui les
habitants ont besoin de ce service de la
construction
tout à fait nous a tout à fait ça c'est
pas tout à fait un service public mais
ça y est entré c'est contribuer parce
qu'on a des très bonnes relations avec
les jeunes pour que justement les
services le service privé à un moment
c'est d'économie sociale et solidaire
puisse bénéficier à la population donc
ça c'est le premier axe le deuxième nous
à nous l'avons dit le développement de
la ville pour répondre à des besoins de
logement et d'emploi des questions
d'emploi sont centrales il faut donc
pouvoir y répondre et puis le troisième
c'est effectivement comment la
population participe à la vie locale à
la fois partout les démarches de
concertation d'associations mais aussi
parce qu'ils se sont des acteurs
centraux de la bille 1 et donc il faut
développer toutes ces démarches on sait
que dès le mois de septembre parce que
je présume que la campagne
pour vous dès le mois de septembre
comment vous allez mener campagne est ce
que vous allez justement faire
participer la population
tout à fait on va effectivement mettre
en place des ateliers de travail avec
les habitants l'a déjà cette démarche
initiée depuis pas mal de temps donc ça
ça devrait être assez facile de pouvoir
les faire participer sur nos grands
sujets il ya des questions sur qu'elle
n'a pas toujours des réponses nous des
aigus et ses réponses viennent aussi de
la production collective avec les
habitants qui donnent leur point de vue
qui donne des idées et de cela peuvent
naître des projets qui correspond bien à
notre commune dernière question est ce
que pierre salaun court quand même
marqué vraiment de son empreinte la
verrière jouera un rôle dans votre
campagne il sera à mes côtés c'est
évident il accompagnera la campagne de
par son expérience sa connaissance de la
ville des personnes évidemment il sera
là bien évidemment il aura pas un euro
qui trouent le président de regarder il
va occuper
vraisemblablement et une place
importante dans le comité de soutien qui
en général se crée toujours dans ses
campagnes là pour accompagner l'équipe
qui se présentent tout à fait dans la
continuité et voilà voilà on va
continuer à part évidemment politique
dans cette émission consacrée aux
municipales on va parler plus longuement
de l'idée avec vous pierre leguérinel
mais avant on va regarder ce reportage
consacré à l'ump l'ump qui a désigné
certains de ses candidats pour les
municipales on regarde cela on détaille
les premières investitures de l'ump pour
les municipales de mars 2014 ont été
connus ce lundi soir elle concerne tout
d'abord les communes qui ne sont pas
détenues par la droite dans le
département ainsi sur le secteur de
saint quentin en yvelines aurore bergé a
été confirmée à magny les hameaux
ladislas cura à guyancourt pour ce qui
concernait les villes de trappes et de
la verrière les investitures ne seront
pas connus avant l'automne à bois d'arcy
c'est philippe benassaya directeur de la
communication à la mairie d'elancourt
qui a été choisi pour faire basculer la
commune actuellement menée par le
socialiste claude juillet pour mort pas
la situation n'est pas tranchée grégory
gare et ce qui a été confirmé comme chef
de file de l'ump dans la commune mais
l'investiture n'a pas encore été
officiellement donnée dans l'attende un
accord local avec lui dis lui dénie à
maurepas est représentée par pierre
leguérinel premier maire adjoint et qui
assure actuellement l'intérim en
l'absence pour raisons médicales
maire divers gauche georges mougeot
grégory gare et astier et pierre
leguérinel n'ont pas caché leur souhait
d'être tête de liste en mars prochain